all right don't worry folks we found
them they were just behind us the entire
time
so i'm guessing because jerry started
this now we have to bring things back
when we go somewhere
yeah uh yeah this is a famous
nigita thing what is this jerry uh it is
sasadango of
i know of it um i've heard of it before
but never shall we dig in
yeah yeah so basically this is uh banana
leaves
yeah i'm pretty sure okay and it's just
like a dongle which is like a
not a not a dumpling what's the word for
it mochi yeah yeah oh red bean paste
kind of like
yeah it's kind of like a red bean place
it's a bread bean in it
yeah but basically you just crack this
open i've never actually had one before
i've seen
i know what these are right because i've
seen them around because
all sorts of different uh because i
think there's different types of
sasadango for different areas of japan
wow that's
that wow
i also for joey's birthday i got him a
bottle of wine oh thank you
which i don't know which one you want
joey then i bought one for the trash
taste boys these are both negative wines
oh yeah because you stayed in a onsen
that had a winery in it or something
right yeah
i went to visit it i have didn't xanax
it was like eight hundred dollars a
night and uh
yeah trash today isn't doing that well
yet uh
but yeah no so i did try a lot of the
local wines while i was there and i
thought they were actually pretty good
and i thought why not bring back a wine
for the boys
yeah i noticed with japanese one because
i remember where i went to i can't
remember i think it's kosher valley
where it's kind of like the napa valley
of japan and i tried a lot of the local
wines there
and i find that japanese wines are
either really good or
not so great like there's i've never
tried a japanese wine and i've just been
like
this is like this is okay i love that
that this is considered japanese wine
it's like oh yes my favorite japanese
wine
sveigeltrev i probably butchered that
german
it says japan at the front though so i
know it's good this is like the weirdest
unboxing i've ever done
but uh yeah we we are unboxing this is
really [ __ ] but not at least at all
so you have to uh you because
this thing is uh thick yeah you have to
kind of
take it in small chunks don't don't eat
the whole thing because uh
you will choke on it and possibly die
are you serious oh yeah no people
you know it's like really common uh way
that people die here is they
like a lot of old people die from
choking on dungo and mochi
what yeah health hazard right into this
this thing yeah yeah
this uh this reminds me of a thai dish
there's there's a thai dish of something
similar let's do small chunks here yeah
it's
it's like we we in thailand we have like
banana leaves that are
like sticky rice that are wrapped in
banana leaves
and it's very thick that's actually
pretty nice yeah
i'm not gonna eat it all in one so that
does taste like a banana leaf
i like this yeah that's pretty good
let's get this
i like the flavor though i mean other
than the red i mean like
okay for anyone who hasn't tried red
bean paste
it's how do you describe to someone who
hasn't tried red bean paste before
oh dude it's weird i don't it's hard
yeah you guys like it right i like it
but it's
it's grown on me red bean paste was that
one thing where
as like i don't know somebody grew up in
the west
my idea of uh my idea of like
dessert or sweets basically just boiled
down to chocolate and ice cream
right like if i'm if i'm feeling like
super fancy or something
something like a tiramisu or
having [ __ ] like red bean paste and like
red like like mochi and stuff i'm like
man this tastes really good yeah the
i've always been fascinated in the whole
like
japanese sweets like culture i guess
like culture they go crazy
yeah it's called wagashi for those of
you want to know um but like dango
mochi that kind of stuff is like it's
weird because
a lot of wag actually a lot of japanese
sweets can either be sweet
or depending on what you put with it
they can also be savory mm-hmm
so it's like a it's like a weird because
like this for example
it's sweet but it's not like a chocolate
yeah sweet right or like a tiramisu
yeah it's it's almost a savory sweet if
that makes sense
but um i mean like my dad for instance
like
can't eat red bean paste just because
it's weird he likes the flavor but he
doesn't like the texture
yeah it's super super thick yeah it's
just basically
it's like grainy right yeah yeah it's
like sludgy i don't know we're throwing
a lot of different adjectives out and
then none of them are matching it's
because
like there's there's nothing i can point
to in like that people can
just ground ground that texture with in
like the west or something it's just
some it's
it's thicker than ice cream but
it's a bit like pasty as well i i don't
[ __ ] know i'm doing it
i'm doing an awful [ __ ] just try it
out just but like the one
the one dessert i i haven't like enjoyed
as much as i thought i would have like
based on the hype that everyone talks
about it
is a shaved ice japanese shaved ice
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] it's basically just like
a japanese version of a snow cone
essentially
people [ __ ] love it here and i'm like
just get an ice cream yeah like an ice
cream
sometimes you don't want an ice cream
sometimes you want something a little
more refreshing than an ice cream
i don't know i don't know like because
here there are some shaved ice places
that people will
line up to for [ __ ] an hour okay i
don't get that [ __ ]
like i'll just [ __ ] make it at home
like i'm not gonna like because there
are some like shaved ice places that are
like
there's stores that specialize in shave
ice yeah and i'm like what's the
difference between making it at home
making here it's like oh no
like maylene [ __ ] because just of
course this she's a [ __ ] food critic
right our producer
she's like oh i found this like amazing
shaved ice place but there's like a two
hour line every year i'm like why are
people lining up for it's like oh it's
like fluffy
like that's not what i look for you guys
after like
two minutes after you've been given it
like it all just starts melting to the
point where it just doesn't taste good
it's just it's just slush yeah it's like
it's having a slush puppy with extra
sugar on it
yeah and like i i don't like it the
places when they just have like
chocolate sauce squirted on [ __ ] like
how can you sit there and tell me
something is worth two hours wait when
you've just put got a bottle of
like chocolate squeeze [ __ ] like
hershey's chocolate it's like it's like
this [ __ ]
you can't you literally have to put
chocolate sauce on water and people are
lining up two hours for this [ __ ] you
kidding me
like gelato that [ __ ] is amazing man i
love that [ __ ]
it's so fresh i like gelato like gelato
gang rice
oh no i i absolutely love jelly i had
like proper
authentic gelato in uh it's all right
what the [ __ ] do you mean it's all right
i had to stop my thoughts
just thinking and i'm like excuse me
just thick ice cream let's be honest
guys
let's let's let's let's not let's let's
not build parts let's not build this up
you have one [ __ ] bite and you're
like
man i just had a three-course meal on
that buy i'm good okay okay i had i had
legit like i don't know we'd say
homegrown
yeah i had it i had like legit gelato in
like florence in italy yeah
that [ __ ] was the [ __ ] oh yeah it's the
best i i thought gelato
here and like in australia was good but
then i had it in florence i'm like damn
this hits different
italians man they know how to make a
[ __ ] gelato oh they don't know i love
you guys
yeah florence please make me chill out
never change never change never change
never change yeah but um i don't know
like are there any other like japanese
sweets that you guys
melon pen's great melon pan yeah is that
considered a sweet uh yeah i mean
it's that just that just goes back to
the bread conversation
well like a lot a lot of things just
happen to be sweet but are they
really sweet it's more of a sweet than
bread yeah
well yeah things like melon pan and like
chocolate cornets
are considered like kashbang which is uh
sweet bread
or like uh confectionary bread that's
what it's called yeah yeah chocolate
cornet
like the ice cornetto no no no no that's
what i thought as well i'm like
talking about cornetto no no chocolate
cornets are like the ones that
[ __ ] that corner to eat in lucky star
oh
like the the little like swirly yeah the
chocolate the poopy ones the poopy ones
yeah yeah
they look like poop but it's the poopy
bread right and you bite it and then
there's like black [ __ ] just comes out
and it's just like
okay yeah no so like this
i'll show you but like you've definitely
seen it it's got like the big hole at
the bottom where the chop where they
squeezed the chocolate into
and the the entire debate like lucky
stuff started this entire debate of like
which side do you eat the chocolate
corner from the fat end or the thicken
yeah and they that the entire first
episode of lucky stuff is that
that's how an anime opens yeah yeah but
it's great but like those but there's
lots of
those kinds of bread in japan and then
there's like the
the savory bread right yeah but for some
reason they also make the savory bread
sweet in a sense so i'm just just
nothing there's just
there's just nothing that's savory
there's nothing savory when it comes to
bread there's nothing safe it's weird
weird enough like this kind of [ __ ] is
more savory sometimes yeah than the
bread that you get right
what'd you want something savory okay so
just a little bit of sugar right it's
like no no no no sugar so
just just i don't understand just one
teaspoon of sugar is that is that what
you're talking about
it goes back to the whole like thai dish
with this spice right it's like what do
you mean no spice
that's not an option yeah it's like one
chili right